foreign
Josh is with us Josh is in Louisville
Kentucky hi Josh how are you
thanks for having me on sure what's up
so wanting to eliminate credit card debt
by the end of 2023
but on the main income of my household
and my wife kind of has a hobby that she
has to decide but
that's not enough to really tackle the
eliminate the credit card debt so I'm
wondering is it time to give up the
Hobby and pursue a you know get her to
get a quote unquote real job what's
y'all's income at this point
combined
combined we're looking at
approximately 60
000 53 from me and then seven
from her
you said 63 from you and seven from her
so 70
no uh 53 for me and then seven okay a
60k total and um you said it's credit
card debt is that's all the debt you
have in the world uh besides the
mortgage is it just the credit cards or
is that just what you feel like you're
focusing on right now it's credit card
okay and how much
fourteen four thousand
and you guys are working the baby steps
in order have you guys
yeah we've tried you know the envelope
and then budget you know all the
spreadsheets and we've tried you know
the different methods and you know it's
easy to stick for you know
a short period of time but then
you know
see and get off course and then yes you
earning more money is not going to make
you stay the course
and I think it's great to earn more
money I'm never opposed to that Dave but
you sticking to your budget and you guys
deciding that this is the plan we're
working the plan that's got nothing to
do with you earning money you sticking
to your budget doesn't have anything to
do with you earning more money or not
that's you just deciding that you and
your wife getting together deciding and
saying this is what we're doing and
we're we're pinky swearing on this and
we we are trusting each other that this
is the plan and we're keeping our word
on that yeah what do you do
I work in finance
how old are you
31 so you're working 40 hours
yes sir okay and what's her hobby that
you're you're calling a hobby she works
but she's done making money at it so
she's got a side hustle that's breaking
even she's an artist
in what type of artist
uh she paints and Designs uh jewelry so
she's an acrylic artist I see okay and
she puts y'all have children
yes we have one child he's five okay and
how much time does she put into acrylic
art to make seven thousand dollars a
year
the holiday season is the busiest time
and so she's putting in
uh sometimes it's the rest of the year
though after the holiday season's over
she's not putting in three hours four
hours a week on it
oh no total during the down Seasons I
mean it's probably total per week you
know 12 to 20. yeah so no it's 12.
um it's not a 20. not sure otherwise
you'd have a house full of this crap
because it wasn't selling or you're
selling it for a penny a piece so uh no
so yeah I think she keeps her Hobby and
she picks up a side hustle and you pick
up a side hustle and the two of you
commit to doing a budget
and then you pay off this debt in a year
why don't you work twice as hard as her
that'd be okay
this is the Ramsey Show